hey there friends so every year I do a
check-in video where I talk about what
sets of poy I actually use this year I
thought I was going to try and simplify
matters and have fewer rather than more
poy on the table and
well didn't quite work out that
way Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain and today I am showing you what
poy I use normally in my day-to-day life
and which poy I prefer before we dive in
though I just want to give a quick shout
out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark bunk fire meca flow fests
flow toys juggling calling pyrro teror
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- buus friend of the channel Becca
Becken thank you so much for supporting
my channel my work and my mission all
right so clearly there's a lot on this
table in front of me in fact there are
probably more sets of poi in front of me
this year than there were when I did
this video last year and there's a few
reasons for that um number one is that
uh several of these are sets of poi that
I used during private lessons I always
try to match the sets of poy that my
students are using in order to try and
make sure that I'm fully understanding
The Experience they're having learning
everything and also too some of these
are special purpose po that I pull out
just for specific uh incidences or
events or purposes that otherwise never
get used but it happens often enough
that they're still in Common Rotation so
with all that in mind I would love to
take you through uh every single set of
poi that I use frequently from fire po
to LED POI and daytime practice POI so
you get a rough idea of what I use in my
own personal practice and performance so
we're going to go ahead and move through
everything on the table from this side
to this side starting
with
firep all right so full
disclosure I have not set my hands on a
set of fire Poise since last August
uh I think the last time I lit up a set
of fire poy was at Great Lakes flow and
the set of fire poy that I used then
were these right here these are a set of
fire poy from uh crispy clowns that I
modded Uh custom with a set of uh Ultra
knob Pros I want to say they are from uh
from Ultra poy the I just like using LED
knobs on my firep now so I can see them
it makes things like you know uh
doing things like Gunslingers and throws
a lot easier um also oh I hate opening
these up like this but you can see on
the inside here these are monkey fist
heads so the whole reason that I use
these is that uh they have these super
absorbent cores to them and they last
forever um I've had these point now for
several years and I'll still get a good
like five or six minute burn out of them
which is fantastic normally after that
long um you start encountering
situations where in uh the burn time is
significantly dropped
so they're great for burn time and I
highly recommend adding LED handles to
them I don't know that I would recommend
these for beginners though simply
because the burn time is so bloody long
but what I would recommend for beginners
is the other set of fire poy that I have
on the table here and these are a set
Elite firep from fire Mecca uh they have
uh different style heads I don't
actually want to pull them out here
they're Moon Blaze style heads um and
they have the feature that I think is
the most awesome feature that uh fire
Mecca poy have which is inside of these
technora tethers here they have a steel
safety cable it makes the tether just a
little bit more stiff than usual but the
trade-off to that is that if you have a
tech nor fail and yes that that does
tend to happen um the steel safety cable
will get you through the rest of your
burn and you won't have to worry about
your poy heads going flying off into the
audience something that I have seen
happen a few times um so and I will do
this with all the sets of Po that I'm
featuring here uh I'm going to go ahead
and leave a link down in the description
to where uh you can pick these up and uh
I have a promo code with fire Mecca you
can use the code drexfactor at checkout
to get discount on these or any other
set of fire props in their online store
so if you're looking to get into fire
poy these are what I recommend um the
steel safety cable is a great safety
consideration and honestly I think the
lower burn time is a feature rather than
a bug for people who are just starting
out awesome and now with my hands
completely covered in soot it's time to
move on to our next section of the table
here LED
poy cool so I have tried to arrange
these as best as possible by uh company
so we're going to go ahead and work
through them one by one so this is the
only set of programmable poy that I have
here on the table um and there's
partially a good reason for that so uh
this is a set of bubble poy from ignis
uh again I will go ahead and leave a
link to them down in the description um
so these are programmable LED contact
poy I tend to use these when I go out on
the DC bikee party rides uh here in town
just because they're a fun thing to
share with all the bikers on the uh on
the big rides I retired from performing
several years ago uh it just wasn't for
me and so I have these and some other
sets of programmable POI that I like but
I just I I very very rarely use them
anymore simply because I just don't have
cause to and also has to be said I still
think that ignis has what is by far the
best smartphone app for controlling POI
out there by a huge margin all right so
moving on we get into Ultra poy
territory and we are actually going to
start this off with a pair of their
Helix po I I actually I believe these
are their Helix poy Pro so it's not
super common but I do have call every so
often to do a video that features some
kind of more glow stringing uh style POI
and these are my go-tos here if you take
a look you can see that I've removed a
lot of the hardware uh on the tethers
here so the tethers are pretty much
directly connected into the heads here
and I've actually removed the swivels
from the other side um I need to
Showcase orbitals like once a year in my
videos so I will just pull out another
set that still have the um the swivels
on them but yeah for the most part when
I'm demonstrating uh glow stringing
inspired tricks these are what I use and
again I prefer minimal hardware for that
awesome so next up the set of ultra poy
that I actually do use most often and
that is going to be these orb poy Pros
here so more than likely you have seen
these in the performance videos that I
do for Ultra poy every month they are
again LED contact poy although these are
not programmable um these are still my
gold star for Simplicity in terms of
using a set of uh LED contact poy you
turn them on it's easy to find a color
you like it's easy to find a mode that
you like you dial that in and they're
ready to go and of course they have the
ultr knobs on the other end uh I love
these for contact tricks I love these
for uh Gunslingers and the like throws
Etc um I was slow to warm up on these
tethers cuz I liked the tethers on the
old uh orb poy so much but I have to
admit these have really grown on me I
quite like them now and of course uh I
have a promo code with ultra po as well
so if you're interested in looking up
those Helix poy or these orb POI or any
other sets of poi that Ultra POI sells
uh you want to use the promo code Drex
factor with a zero instead of an O at
checkout over at Ultra po.com all right
so moving on into our flow toy section
here the first ones I'm going to show
you are my other favorite option for Led
contact po these are floa poy floa poy
of course utilize uh Lantern Smith uh
umoja uh contact poy heads and stick the
capsules from podp inside of them so you
get the best of all worlds you get LED
contact poy and you get all those
awesome programming modes that come with
using uh flow toys's capsule 2.0 system
so I use these a lot in my sponsored
videos from flow toys and also um I used
these for a performance that I
choreographed last year that involved uh
essentially setting up a custom show
inside of the flow toys smartphone app
um I'm still incredibly proud of that
and I'm going to link to that down in
the description uh so you can go check
that out because I think it is some of
the best work that I've ever done and I
really enjoyed being able to program uh
a custom show for these and have it turn
out so incredibly well and next up we
have
the pop and flow POI um specifically we
have the pop and flow POI with the FPC
tethers here these basically take all of
these modes that we love with uh the
flow toys uh LED uh the capsule and
vision system and expand them out into
uh a nice long strip here um I used
these for my review I used them for a
flow video a few months ago I've pulled
them out a few times since I don't know
if they're going to go in the long-term
rotation but they've been used often
enough recently that I thought it was a
good idea to include them here I've been
pleasantly surprised by these uh there
were a lot of things that I was
concerned about in terms of you know
with the pop and flow system being able
to swap out components and how durable
that was going to be and these have
turned out to work wonderfully awesome
next up we have that old stalwart of the
LED po world my podoy so with these I
mainly use these when I'm teaching
lessons I have a couple students that
prefer to use these and again uh I just
want to use the same kind of Po that
they're using so I've got a rough idea
of where they might be running into
trouble and if there's some specific fix
that I can give them that I'm going to
have to that it's important to know what
the props they're using are also has to
be said pod poy are just wonderfully
portable as led POI go uh these fit
really easily into my bag I can take
them around anywhere if I'm having an
evening out where I want to be traveling
light pun not intended uh these are
definitely what I prefer to have on me
and of course I have a promo code for
flow toys that code is Drex Factor uh
52024 that is drexfactor May 2024 but in
digit form and that will get you 10% off
any of the props in the flow toy store
yes even including those pop and flow
props awesome and that takes us to our
final
category daytime or practice po
all right so the first ones I'm going to
show you here are my emoji poy from
Lantern Smith um I have had these for
years I want to say I actually acquired
this pair back in 2018 maybe 2019 I want
to say and so that's now like five six
years that I've had them and they're
still kicking it really really well um I
remain shocked that umoa poy are not the
most popular option for contact point
out there I I just don't get it they're
incredibly flexible I used these last
year when I did my project where I
learned uh G's choreography from his uh
firep performance at San Francisco dcom
and these were really important to me
because they allowed me to dial in uh
accustom weight and for the heads and a
custom length for the tethers and that
just made it so much easier for me to be
able to stay in time with what G was
doing in his video I also have a stud
student who prefers to use emojo po so
these wind up getting used a lot in
lessons too um I don't tend to use these
that frequently on the day today I used
to um now they're more reserved for
lessons than when I have special
projects but I still consider them a
very important part of my PO portfolio
and of course I do have a promo code
through Lantern Smith as well if you use
the code Drex factor with a zero instead
of an O at checkout that gets you 5% off
your own set of Emoji POI or any other
prop in their online store and that just
leaves one more set of poi on this table
and those POI ironically enough are the
POI that I probably use more often than
every other set of poi on this table
combined these are my fabric poy from
sock poy so I have definitely gushed
about these before not only are they
incredibly soft and very very forgiving
when you're trying new things but also
they're incredibly visible I love the
way they show up on video
and of course probably most important of
all these are perhaps in my mind the
platonic ideal of dance po at this point
what do I mean by dance poy well between
their handling and their weight these
are the poy that are always my default
when I go to choreograph something for
some reason just everything lines up
with these they feel really really
comfortable I think they look gorgeous
on video and most important of all they
are super responsive when I'm moving
around whenever I want to make really
really rapid changes these po stick with
me um I usually find with most sets of
contact poy that I kind of have to fight
them a little bit in order to get the
momentum to do what I want them to do
and these are the set of Po that I feel
like facilitate dance rather than the
set of poy that I feel like I have to
fight with in order to make dance happen
and of course like most sets of poy on
this table I have a promo code with the
company that makes these uh if you use
the promo code Drex Factor uh and I
believe uh you now purchase these over
at the neop poy website uh that will get
you a discount on your order um these
are by far my favorite poy to use uh
right now by by a huge huge huge margin
and while we're on the topic of dance
and POI guess what I have a new live
stream POI dance class this month my
live stream po dance class is going in
depth on weaves not only will I teach
you all about weave and transitions in
and out of them but I'll also be
teaching you a full combo that uses
weaves as well as several other po
tricks and that is going to absolutely
Amaze your family and friends you can go
ahead and sign up for that now over at
crowdcast doio drexfactor poy early bird
tickets are available until May 14th
awesome
so these are the most common POI that I
use in
2024 what are the sets of Po that you
are most likely to use Leave Me a
comment and let me know be sure to like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find this video and of
course to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission and if you out there watching
enjoy the videos that I create and you'd
like to see me make more of them in the
future there's an easy way that you can
make that happen and that's to head on
over to patreon and sign up at
patreon.com drexfactor pooy every
donation that people make there helps me
continue to make these videos and also
you get access to some pretty awesome
rewards too so go check that out please
and thank you and if you're really in Ed
by these pop and flow poy I will go
ahead and link to my review of them down
in the description as well as up on
screen I had quite the fun adventure
getting over my fear of taking them
apart and putting them back together so
you can go experience that with me thank
you so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace